[Music]
we are so obsessed with The Descendants
movies and can't wait to see the new
characters pop up in the third one stay
tuned to see which actresses and actors
we think should show up on your screen
in descendants three are you new around
here don't forget to give this video a
big thumbs up and subscribe to the
things for more videos like this now on
to 10 possible new descendants three
characters
Tiana's daughter so the princess in the
frog is one of our favorite disney
movies
why because tiana was a total boss she
worked hard for what she wanted and made
her dreams a reality which is why we are
just dying to see how Tiana's daughter
will turn out wouldn't she make a great
addition to the descendants cast and who
should play her we are thinking sky
Jackson she's so cute and a phenomenal
actress that we know that she would do
an amazing job we can just imagine sky
as Tiana's daughter being one of our
fave numbe
what do you think else's daughter in
frozen elsa toad the line between being
a heroine and a villain
she was never evil but she did allow her
powers to make her angry and shut
everyone out which was pretty darn mean
of her so what better character to be in
descendants than someone who is not
fully a goody two-shoes we would love to
see what else's daughter would be like
would she have the same powers as her
mother would she be better at mastering
her powers or would she be completely
different to play the role we think
bella thorne would be amazing
she and Doug Cameron are already really
great friends so they wouldn't have to
work hard to have on-screen chemistry
max goof goofy may be one of the
funniest characters that Disney has ever
come out with thanks to a goofy movie
we already know who Goofy's son is his
name is max goof and he's a pretty cool
guy if you ask us but we wonder how max
would do in the world of descendants
Disney favourite Jake short would be
perfect playing max we would love to see
him stretch himself and play the shy yet
lovable son of goofy we would especially
love if goofy himself made an appearance
or two Prince Hans his son you remember
Prince Hans yeah the one that tried to
trick on into falling in love with
just so we could take over the kingdom
yeah him can you imagine if he ever had
a kid with the kid be as evil and
conniving as Hans or would they have
more of a conscience than they're
scheming father we would love to see
Bradley Stephen Carey play the role yeah
we know he is already voicing a
character on the animated descendants
series wicked world but he is not an
official character in the movies yet
Freddy fassl the heir speaking of the
short animated series wicked world one
particular character that we would love
to see is Freddy Bassel here she is the
daughter of dr. Faso leer who is the
villain in The Princess and the Frog
he was so sinister that he almost made
the movies scary at times we know that
china anne mcclain voiced Freddy in the
first season which is probably why they
couldn't add her to any movies since
China already had a role in the film but
now that her sister Lauren McClain is
the voice of the character we can add
Freddy to the film's syndromes daughter
depending on how big a Disney fan you
are you may or may not remember Syndrome
he was the villain from Pixar's film The
Incredibles not only was this guy super
evil but he was also super hilarious
what more could you ask for in a villain
so if Syndrome went on to have a kid we
would love to see how they turned out
especially if he had a daughter
can you imagine syndrome and girl
teenage form Sierra McCormick would be
the perfect actress to play the part you
remember her from ant farm don't you if
so wouldn't she be perfect on his son
okay since we added Elsa to the list
then we can't leave out Anna Anna was
basically the backbone of frozen without
her the movie would have just ended
after Elsa ran away Anna was courageous
and she was resourceful so we would love
to see how her kid turned out would he
be as brave as she was and how would her
kid get along with her sisters we have
to see Doug Brochu could play the role
he was good and sunny with the chance
Pocahontas his daughter Pocahontas is
one of the Disney Princesses that
doesn't really get the respect that she
deserves people always forget about her
but in the movie she saves her people
from a massive war with the colonists as
well as saves the man that she loves
from being hurt give the girl some
recognition since Pocahontas was such an
amazing woman wouldn't you love to
how her daughter turns out we think that
ariana grande would be a perfect choice
to play Pocahontas his daughter she's
fierce and could carry on Pocahontas his
legacy well besides it's about time
Ariana made her way back to acting
anyway isn't it Ariel's daughter who is
your favorite redhead Disney Princess
your answer better be Ariel okay Merida
from brave is also pretty awesome but we
are focusing on Ariel right now Ariel
has been such a staple in the Disney
World for so long that it's strange that
they haven't incorporated her or her
children into the descendants yet plus
you know her kids will have to be
gorgeous just look at her in Prince Erik
their genes are insane who would we like
to see play this role well only one star
could pull it off and that's Selena
Gomez Selena are you ready to come back
to Disney Alice in Wonderland's daughter
most disney movies tend to err on the
safe side of things the movies are after
all intended for children but one film
breaks that mold and that is Alice in
Wonderland that movie was downright
weird and so was Alice herself that's
why we need Disney to bring her
weirdness into the world of descendants
can you imagine what her daughter would
be like let's get Peyton lists to play
this character she would be perfect for
the role she already kind of resembles
Alice don't you think it's too perfect a
chance to pass up do you hear us Disney
make it happen and that's it for 10
possible new descendants three
characters are there any more characters
that you would like to see in this new
movie let us know in the comments thanks
for watching
[Music]